Look at that, Frank.
This is a original
Great Northern
Railroad bench out of a depot.
MIKE: Oh, wow.
Is this something you'd sell?
I think I would.
You know, this is
how far it got.
You're not doing
too much with it.
MIKE: What I do know about
the Great Northern Railroad,
it ran from St. Paul,
Minnesota all the way
to Seattle, Washington.
I'd like to pull it out of
here to see what it looks like.
All right, let's pull it
out, see what it looks like.
MIKE: This thing would have
been sitting outside the depot.
People waiting for their
World War I veterans
to come home, World War II
veterans to come home, or maybe
a presidential whistle-stop.
NARRATOR: In the lead
up to the 1948 election,
President Truman has
traveled over 20,000
miles across the nation.
Millions of people have turned
out to see the president
and hear his message.
This is probably 1903, '04.
FRANK: Early 1900s.
BRIAN: Yes.
MIKE: Brian is one
of those guys that
has gone beyond just the
picking part of this business.
He's actually researching
the history of pieces.
My depot is 1906.
And the railroad got to
this town before Beacon.
OK.
So this would have
been the front.
Yeah.
It's missing one
of the brackets, one
of the little dividers there.
MIKE: What are you
thinking on it, Brian?
Well, it's the only one
I've ever come across.
A $300 bench?
It's original out of a depot.
This is great.
I like it, but--
this piece to be
replaced is like--
FRANK: That's hen's teeth.
MIKE: Yeah, I mean,
you're not going to find
the one with a star on it.
This is for larger
people this section.
Oh, is that what it is?
That's what it is.
[laughing]
It's for you and your
girlfriend sitting there.
- Yeah.
You can sit together.
Honestly, I'll
tell you what, Brian.
I'd be a player on this
thing for 200 bucks.
I wouldn't be--
I think if it had
that piece on it, I--
$250.
It's original.
230 bucks.
$240.
Final deal.
All right, you guys
got it it done.
I decided to sell because
I've got a complete disaster
in a really cool train depot.
Can you show us?
Absolutely.
Come on in, guys.
I didn't clean.
- OK, that's good.
- We hope not.
- We like it dirty.
We like it that way.
Oh, wow.
FRANK: Well, now we're talking.
Yeah.
Well, what else we got in here?
I hid a pedal car
down there years ago.
I think it's--
- Right here?
- Yeah.
FRANK: Jump on in there.
Here, move this penguin.
[grunting]
Jeepers!
What if you don't buy
it when you get to it?
Well, I gotta see
what it looks like.
Brian tells me the story of
him hiding it because he thinks
someone's gonna steal it.
Freakin' doing what
my brother would do.
All right, here we go.
The grand finale.
BRIAN: Holy, man!
That was buried!
Ha!
Holy [bleep]!
Wow.
Pedal car.
It's got a good look to it.
Look at that bad boy.
He's got it.
MIKE: I yank the pedal car out.
It's got some wacky
fender flares on it.
It's one I've never
even seen before.
Somebody repainted it.
It's got the wrong
steering wheel on it.
What's with the wire
holding everything together?
Is that just holding
the front end on?
See the wire?
See the wire in front?
Is that holding--
Yeah, it's just holding that.
It's missing the bolt to
the front end is what it is.
Yeah, I can see
it's separating.
Yeah.
- See what I mean?
- I think this--
I don't know, man.
Rummage sale in Devil's Lake.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out what
the T would have been on it.
FRANK: Maybe that's for Tesla.
[laughing]
$200.
MIKE: I worked hard
to get this thing out.
BRIAN: $185.
I'll give you
125 bucks for it.
That's how hard I worked.
FRANK: There you go.
Thanks, man.
I didn't spend a
lot of money on it.
And he really did work for that.
What we've got here is a
collection of Elvis Presley.
Every one of these are Elvis.
"Elvis Greatest Hits,"
"Elvis Blue Hawaii,"
"Elvis Back in Memphis,"
the "Golden Records."
So it looks like
something got onto it
or something scratched it up.
Cat got it, they told me.
Cat got it or
something like that.
Most of these records are
from the '60s and '70s.
Elvis was the man.
He was making comeback specials.
He was selling out
shows in Las Vegas.
He was even hanging out with
Nixon at the White House.
NARRATOR: The King
arrived at the White House
bearing a gift for
the president--
a Colt 45 pistol, which the
Secret Service confiscated.
That's pretty bad.
Do you know what I mean?
You see it?
Ah.
Yeah.
It's got definite
scratches in it.
So I would just-- you know,
I would think some of them
are good, maybe some
are bad, you know?
What do you think?
BRIAN: $50.
- You got it.
- Thank you.
$50.
Elvis Presley.